let me ask you about P
Doom probability of Doom that's just fun
to say but not fun to
experience uh what is to you the
probability that AI eventually kills all
or most humans also known as probability
of
Doom I'm not a fan of that calculation I
think it's uh people just throw numbers
out there uh it's a very sloppy Cal
calulation right take calculate a
probability you know let's say you model
the world as some sort of Markoff
process if you have enough variables or
hidden Markoff process you need to do a
stochastic path integral through the
space of all possible Futures not just
the Futures that your brain naturally
steers towards right um I think that the
estimators of pom are biased because of
our biology right we we've evolved
to have bias sampling towards negative
Futures that are scary because that was
an evolutionary Optimum right and so
people that are of let's say higher
neuro
neuroticism will just think of uh
negative Futures where everything goes
wrong all day every day and and claim
that
they're doing unbiased sampling and and
in a sense like they're not normalizing
for the space of all possibilities and
the space of all possibilities is like
super exponentially
large and it's very hard to have this
estimate and in general I don't think
that we can predict the future with with
that much
granularity because of of chaos right if
you have a complex system you have some
uncertainty and a couple variables if
you let time evolve you have this
concept of a a liapunov exponent right a
bit of fuzz becomes a lot of fuzz in our
estimate exponentially so uh over time
and um I think we we need to show some
humility uh that we can't actually
predict the future all we know the only
prior we have is the laws of
physics and that's that's what we're
arguing for the laws of physics say the
system will want to grow and subsystems
that are optimized for growth are more
and replication are more likely in the
future and so we should aim to maximize
our current Mutual information with the
future and the path towards that is for
us to accelerate rather than
decelerate so I don't have a p Doom
because I think that you know similar to
the quantum Supremacy experiment at
Google I was in the room when they were
running the simulations for that that
was was an example of a Quantum chaotic
system where you you cannot even
estimate probabilities of certain
outcomes uh with even the biggest
supercomputer in the world right and um
so that's an example of chaos and I
think the system is far too chaotic for
anybody to have an accurate uh estimate
of the likelihood of certain Futures if
they were that good I think they would
be very rich uh trading on the stock
market but nevertheless it's true that
humans are biased grounded in our
evolutionary
biology scared of everything that can
kill us but we can still imagine
different trajectories that can kill us
we don't
know uh all the other ones that don't
necessarily but it's still I think
useful combined with some basic
intuition grounded in human history to
reason about like what like looking at
geopolitics looking at
basics of human nature how can powerful
technology hurt a lot of
people it just seems in grounded in that
looking at nuclear weapons you can start
to
estimate P
Doom in this in a maybe in a more
philosophical sense not not a
mathematical one philosophical meaning
like is there a chance does human nature
tend to towards that or
not I I think to me one of the biggest
existential risks would be the
concentration of the power of AI in the
hands of the very few especially if it's
a mix between the companies that control
the flow of information and the
government because that could uh set
things up for a sort of dystopian future
where only a very few and all got in the
government have ai and they could even
convince the public that AI never
existed and that opens up sort of these
scenarios for
authoritarian centralized control which
to me is the The Darkest Timeline and
the reality is that we have we have a
prior we have a data driven prior of
these things happening right when you
give too much power when you centralize
power too much um humans do horrible
things right um and to me that has a
much higher likelihood in my basian
inference than uh sci-fi based priors
right like my prior came from the
Terminator movie um and so when I talk
to these AI doomers I just asked them to
trace a path through this Markoff chain
of events that would lead to our Doom
right and to actually give me a good
probability for each transition and very
often there's a unphysical or highly
unlikely transition in that chain right
but of course we're wired to fear things
and we're wired to respond to danger and
we're wired
to deem the unknown to be dangerous
because that's a good heuristic for
survival right but there's much more to
lose out of fear uh uh we have so much
to lose so much upside to lose by
preemptively stopping the positive
futures from from happening out of fear
um and so I think that we shouldn't uh
give into fear fear is the mind killer I
think it's also the civilization killer
we can still think about the various
ways things go wrong for example the
founding fathers of this of the United
States thought about human nature and
that's why there's a discussion about
the freedoms that are
necessary they really deeply deliberated
about that and I think the same could
possibly be done for AGI it is true that
history human history
shows that we tend towards
centralization or at least when we
achieve centralization a lot of bad
stuff happens when there's a
dictator a lot of dark bad things happen
the question is can AGI become that
dictator can AGI when develop become the
centralizer because of its power maybe
has the same because of the alignment of
humans perhaps the same Tendencies the
same uh Stalin like Tendencies to
centralize and manage centrally the
allocation of resources and you can even
see that as an compelling argument on
the surface level well AGI is so much
smarter so much more efficient so much
better at allocating resources why don't
we Outsource it to the
AGI and then eventually whatever forces
that uh corrupt the human mind with
power could do the same for AGI you'll
just say well humans dispensable we'll
get rid of them do the Jonathan Swift
Modest
Proposal from a few centuries ago I
think the
1700s when he satirically suggested that
I think it's in Ireland that the the
children of poor people are fed as food
to the rich people and that would be a
good idea because it decreases the
amount of poor people and gives extra
income to the poor people so it's on
several accounts decreases the amount of
poor people therefore more people become
rich uh of course it misses a
fundamental piece here here that's hard
to put into a mathematical equation of
the basic value of human
life so all of that to say are you
concerned about AGI being the very
centralizer of power that you just
talked
about I do think that um right now
there's a bias towards over
centralization of AI because of uh
compute density and centralization
centralization of data and how we're
training U models um I think over time
we're going to run out of data to scrape
over the internet and I think that well
actually I'm working on increasing the
compute density so that compute can be
everywhere and acquire information and
test hypothesis in the environment in a
distributed uh fashion I think that
fundamentally centralized cybernetic
control so having one intelligence that
is massive that you know fuses
many sensors and is trying to perceive
the world accurately predict it
accurately predict many many variables
and control it right enact its will upon
the world I think that's just never been
the optimum right like let's you have uh
a company you know if you have a company
I don't know of 10,000 people that all
report to the CEO even if that coo was
an AI I think it would struggle to fuse
all of the information that is coming to
it and then predict the whole system and
then to enact its its will what has
emerged in nature and in corporations
and all sorts of systems is a notion of
sort of hierarchical cybernetic control
right you have uh you know in a company
would be you have like the individual
contributors they're self-interested and
and and uh they're trying to achieve
their their tasks and they they have a a
fine in terms of time and space if you
will control Loop and and field of
perception right um they have their code
base let's say you're in a software
company they have their code base they
iterate it on it uh intraday right and
then the management maybe checks in it
has a wider scope it has let's say five
reports right and then it samples each U
person's update once per week and then
you can go up the chain and you have
larger time scale and greater scope and
that seems to have emerged as sort of
the
the optimal way to to control systems
and and really that's what capitalism
gives us right you have these these
hierarchies and you can even have like
parent companies and so on and so that
is far more fault tolerant in Quantum
Computing that's my feel they came from
we have a a concept of of this fault
tolerance and Quantum air correction
right Quantum a correction is detecting
a fault that came from noise predicting
how it's propag at through the system
and then correcting it right so it's a
cybernetic Loop and it turns out that uh
decoders uh that are hierarchical and at
each level the hierarchy are local uh
perform the best by far and are far more
F toin and the reason is if you have a
non-local decoder then you have one
fault at at this uh control node and the
whole system sort of crashes similarly
to if you have uh you know uh one CEO
that everybody reports to and that CEO
goes on vacation the whole company comes
to crawl right um and so to me I think
that yes we're seeing a tendency towards
centralization of AI but I think there's
going to be a correction over time where
intelligence is going to go closer to
the perception and we're going to we're
going to break up AI into um um smaller
subsystems that communicate with one
another and and form a sort of meta uh
system so if you look at the hierarchies
there in the world today there's Nations
and those all hierarchical but in
relation to each other nations are
anarchic so it's an
anarchy would you do you forese a world
like this where there's not a
over what you call it a centralized
cybernetic control centralized Locust of
control yeah so like that's suboptimally
you're saying
yeah so it would be always a state of
competition at the very top level yeah
just like you know in a company you may
have like uh two units working on
similar technology and competing with
one other and you you prune the one that
performs not as well right and that's a
sort of selection process for a tree or
a product gets killed right and then a
hole or gets fired and that's this
process of of trying new things and and
and shedding old things that didn't work
is this it's what gives us adaptability
and helps us Converge on uh you know the
Technologies and things to do that are
most good I just hope there's not a
failure mode that's unique to AGI versus
Humans CU you're describing human
systems mostly right now right I just
hope when there's a monopoly on AGI in
one company that we'll see the same
thing we see with humans which is
another company will spring up start
competing effectively that's been the
case so far right we have open AI we
have anthropic now we have
xai uh you know we had Meta Even for
open source was and now we have mistol
right which is highly competitive and so
that's the beauty of capitalism you
don't have to trust any one party too
much cuz we're kind of always hedging
our bets at every level there's always
competition and that's the most um
beautiful thing to me at least is that
the whole syst system is always shifting
and always adapting and maintaining that
dynamism is how we avoid tyranny right M
making sure that um everyone has access
to to these tools to to these models and
can contribute to the research uh um
avoids a sort of neural tyranny where
very few p PE people have control over
AI for the world and and use it to
oppress uh those around them